[Music]
my name is mickey malcolm
orioni from venezuela
and i'm the founder of rivet capital
based in silicon valley
an entrepreneur who build their
companies in latin america and europe
and in the u.s
and um i want to start i want to
i'm very happy to make this panel uh
work today
and uh an honor with the people that are
here i'll start and when we can we can
take it from here uh so let me start
with a very
um
quick
question what do you get
when you put two colombians two
venezuelans
one brazilian and one argentine in the
room
i think you get a better soccer team a
better football team
let's start with quick introductions
around around the table all of you are
are around some of the most successful
and better known brands and companies in
latin america all of you
are from different places in latin
america but all of you share one very
important topic you all attended an mba
and you all attended the nba at stanford
at the gsb
so
um
we have people that go uh marcos is our
older statement here he's
yes he's class of 99 and i'm not gonna
keep going because it will make anybody
else but uh
i'll go if you can quickly introduce
yourselves even even though you know
each other uh but for the rest of the
people that are attending the webinar
just quickly
when you went when what year you
attended business school uh and what do
you do today and then we can start with
some questions about about stanford
about the business program and about
latin america
marcus you're the older statement so
we're going to start with you
even hi everyone
hi everyone how are you i'm marcos
galperin i attended gsb
97-99 and i started marcoliude out of
the gsb
actually drove my first investor to the
airport from a class at the gsb
lori
hi everyone um lorian garcia most people
call me laurie i went to the gsd from
2008 to 2010
and i'm a co-founder i'm one of kavac's
co-founder currently i lead everything
related to culture and organization and
we started quebec about
six years after i graduated from the gsb
welcome lori and
gabriel david
hello everybody i'm gabrielle braga from
brazil
i went to the just be from 2010 to 12
together with davey
and a few other entrepreneurs in the
region i started kintvanda right after
school actually we we started discussing
the idea during school and came back to
brazil uh to start it
and hello everyone david
also
uh from 2010 to
originally from colombia
started new bank also right after
business school end of 2012 beginning of
2013.
hello nemo
hi everybody i don't nemo river from
medellin
i went to gsb
2012-2014
i started doing getting into real estate
before gsb
and it was something i was very
passionate about and
during gsb went deeper into it
and right after gsb started doing
traditional real estate and started
covering with the idea of something or
doing something different around 2017
and that's what led to to what i'm
currently doing at the house
well welcome to all of you it's a
privilege to have you here and to
dedicate this next 45 minutes to talk
about uh
an mba why it matters so let me just
throw out this first uh
very simple question of
of all the things you could have done
when you look back in time
why did you choose to do an mba
and any we can do a free flow i can ask
each one or you can just go and start
and just intervene why do you choose to
do this
who wants to start i can i can start
there we go
um i remember you know a few years ago i
i was looking into into grad school and
when i did my research i realized that
an mba would it was the most complete
program that i could find like most
master's degree would probably you focus
on something professional and learning a
skill during the mba especially at the
gsp you go through a personal
transformation and a professional
transformation because it's not just
about going to class it was about the
people you meet the classmates and all
the new things that i would be exposed
to and i wanted to go to to to stanford
because i you know i love
that the what they were always saying
about changing the world and i wanted to
be part of that
yeah for myself i i i went to you know
undergrad in brazil i always started in
brazil had the chance to to study some
good schools here but you know didn't
have the kind of world-class exposure
that uh that no you can have any school
like like stanford
and besides the the academic and the
professional impact that that could
bring my life i think was it would be
you know a different person
after spending two years with people
from all over the world different
culture different religions different
backgrounds all kind of uh you know
different things that can influence uh
my personality my understanding about
how things work uh you know globally and
eventually even my kids can you know can
be friends with with the kids of of of
my friends from nba that are from all
over the world and do a bunch of
interesting things
and i think specifically about stanford
was a very small community that i think
would have a deeper connection with
those people
and be exposed to the silicon valley
which was
you know a big dream for myself
uh you know sometimes is excuse for you
to to spend uh two years or more in the
middle in the heart of of no tech
innovation in the world
to me it was it was a
a bit of a moment to take a step back i
had already been in business i was i was
doing investing
for a few years before business school i
always wanted to be an entrepreneur but
i didn't really see a clear path of
just simply leaving the job and
then figuring out how to start something
so
it was a bit of a breather to take a
step back and understand okay what's the
next
10 20 years of my life going to look
like
uh and can i take opportunity of those
years to do some switches to meet more
people
to work in some skill sets in a way it
was
almost everything beyond the business
the business aspect was actually the
least interesting part to me it was more
about the
non-business classes as well as the
community
and the people that i was expecting to
meet and frankly just the time and the
network that was going to give me a
little bit of a breather to try to
understand that so
uh so from that perspective i think
worked out really really well
who who was a bigger party or socializer
in uh gabrielle or you in that class
i i think it was pretty competitive
i must say the v was the main idiot
yeah the visa yeah
you gave you competed hard
i don't know i think we tied
marcos oh yeah i think similar to what
has been said i also wanted to take a
breather uh i might add i was
particularly attracted at stanford
because of the golf course which was
ended up being very important for my
career as well as john donahoe the ceo
of ebay was an avid golfer so that was a
an added skill uh
for me but uh joking aside no i wanted
to spend some time in in the valley i
really wanted to be in the west coast i
had done my undergraduate in the east
coast and
and i was convinced that the the the
entrepreneurship
skills that i was going to learn at
stanford were going to be very useful
for me and it definitely turned out that
way
hero anything to add yeah yeah i think
like for me it was i had to clear what i
didn't want to
what i didn't want to do
like i didn't want to do something
very specific very very technical i just
had the guard feeling that there were
many things to learn
uh about the world and
and and to try different things and i
think like lorianne said the
mba afforded that spectrum
of different things you could expose
yourself to
there's a there's a few questions coming
through the q a that i may throw and
just change a little bit the ones i had
in mind
but um and one one question that comes
here on the thread
that um it's interesting because it's
something that uh i did not go to nba i
did not go to stanford and yet i'm here
helping
promote a program for latin americans to
come to
we we're going to talk more about it
later in towards the end of the
in the end of the chat but one question
that that came around was
do you think it was worth the investment
like you're making a big investment in
yourself
and you're deciding to use that money
or your personal money and time to make
a two-year investment in yourself how do
you think about that versus starting a
company without it it's one of the
questions that came through
through the chat
since all of you have started companies
i think it's it's one of the best panels
in latin america to ask this question
okay let me give that one a try first uh
and
i think it's a great question but
because a lot has changed since well
it's inside definitely since i did my
mba but also i think since my
uh colleagues here as well because of
the availability of online education
that has
uh boomed in the last few years
i think that if you are really thinking
about the
educational experience mostly because of
the skills you want to learn the finance
skills
digital marketing skills or whatever i
think you can get those today
online quite well i think that what
stanford provides is a much more
comprehensive experience i think you
know in my case i literally drove to the
airport the person that invested in in
my company uh my classmate steliotolda
he's been working with me for 23 years
he's a president of the commerce
part of our business
the president of the payment side of our
business a guy was that was doing the
mba one year ahead of me so basically i
built the company with my classmates and
and that is something that you will
never get doing a an educational
experience online so i think it depends
very much on what you're looking to get
from your
from from your mba stanford is really
really unique in in many aspects
yeah i would i would add it i would very
much agree with marcos on that i think
one once one thing that somebody once
mentioned to me is that if you if you
take the long view on your career
and you think you're going to be working
what i don't know we're going to be
working 50 60 70 years who knows
investing two of those
six sixty seven years into a
fundamentally different experience
where you're going to be exposed to
different ideas different people
and uh and open to
to have that network
take you in different unexpected
uh directions is
is a very interesting opportunity
i similar to marcos i ended up working
gsb with sequoia for a year and suddenly
they became my city investor in newbeck
if i hadn't gone to stanford i don't
think i probably would have ever met
them i don't know if i would have ever
even been able to
to raise the capital that i needed for
what i wanted to do
and so
and similarly as i said initially i
think
you wouldn't do business school
necessarily for the business
if you want to do business you want to
do accounting read a book you got the
marketing breed of marketing take a
course
but it's it's all about everything else
that's not the business is the entire
really ecosystem and what you get
exposed to
that makes it a very powerful
two-year investment either from a time
or even from a money perspective
i identify with uh with a quote i heard
joelle peterson say
the last launch i had at the gsb
somebody asked him
that similar question he said
look the
bottom ten percent of people
don't deserve to be here the top ten
percent of people don't need to be here
the for the other eighty percent it's a
transformative experience
i consider myself to be part of that
eighty percent not because i
well i did at the time
i polished my financial skills i
published my marketing skills but it was
a much more comprehensive experience
learning more about the world and
learning more about yourself
and building relationships that really
unleashed a lot of personal value
and it is know to add um i think of
course you can do something you know you
know have a great business without going
through an mba but i think that if if
you go through an mba especially through
stamford it kind of like gives you like
a super power to you know like a super
booster accelerator like i see right now
my day-to-day work most of the things
that i that i that my toolkit that i use
came from stanford everything i learned
in communications knowing how to write
this how to say that how to actually get
people to engage with your message
everything i i learn in in how
in leadership skills and how you
actually build relationships within your
team to be able to achieve something
that goes beyond you know what you could
do by yourself all of that i remember
you know sitting in stanford reading the
books um
practicing role playing and all those
things are the things that i use right
now daily most of my time most of the
time and laurie for you
you carlos your co-founder of kavac and
your brother he went to oxford for his
mba
and you went to stanford how
is there any competition at home around
this topic
nope
you think there would be but there isn't
we could be
so
let me switch a little bit the question
you're you all run now big companies
you're all recruiting a lot of people
when you're in that process now as a as
a founder as
as the leaders of your companies and
you're recruiting
what are you seeing in latin america
what are you seeing from people that are
coming from with education what are you
needing the most what would you like to
see more of and in the same way marcos
was mentioning that
part of his team that runs michael
olivier are all stanford ex-alumni that
did it and i think gabrielle can also
talk a little bit about that uh which i
i think i just jumped and i forgot them
but uh um how do you think about the
that potential of of people coming out
with these programs in your company's
futures maybe we start with you gabe
since since we i forgot to ask you and
you can answer the word i i only agreed
with everybody so uh it would be kind of
a repetitive um
so in in our case our entire almost
entire you know as active team
you know are
are you know were part of of stanford
many of those who were were in the same
class
um
i think that today what we see
is is this you know the people that have
the chance to go through these programs
you know they have a much accelerated
learning curve about other things but
much more uh a faster way to access the
answers or what they need to learn if
sometimes they know already because they
were exposed by that but if they don't
know as laura was saying you know they
can quickly you know
you know tap their network or expand
their horizons there and learn quickly
about those things
and i i i would add to that you know
in latin we are particularly
you know
restricted from people that actually had
experience
doing what we are trying to do you know
in our case was very hard in the
beginning here of know the first cohorts
of startups in brazil
and today i see a big difference of
companies that are starting and can
actually recruit people who that spent a
few years working on the companies and
can come you know and they hit the
ground running because they already were
exposed to that so if you have to chance
to go uh
to a program like this you know you
spend the time working in silicon valley
or other companies it's something that's
it's super valuable for for you coming
back and you wanting to join a company
in brazil that or in latin that usually
you know can't have access to talent
that actually you know uh was exposed to
to doing things like companies in the
u.s have right like you you hire
engineer there they spent you know a few
years on one two three companies that uh
that you're aspiring to be
uh here that's much harder and uh easier
to find with uh people that are in this
network
and
marco since you you've
you've been out of the gsv the longest
if you had to do the nba again why would
you do it differently this time
uh
well
that's a that's a good question i think
you know when i did my my mba i focused
most of my
of my efforts in uh in uh
attending lectures by guest speakers
and building relationships with my
classmates
and uh both on and outside of the golf
course
and i think that's what i would do again
i think that what that was the most
valuable thing
things for me were those just getting
inspired by the amazing uh lecture
speakers that that we would have
uh again one of those ended up investing
in in my company uh and and the and the
incredible
classmates i had uh who basically helped
me build my business but are also many
that are not working in marco liure
lifelong friends that are two different
things and are just an amazing community
uh to to be with so so i think that's
one of the most valuable things
that gsb provides
i didn't get into
more technical
classes at the time i think i would this
these days i would do some programming i
would do i would learn some more code
something i didn't do then i would
definitely uh you know rather than
learning the basic accounting skills or
maybe basic statistics skills i would
definitely learn basic uh
coding skills
uh
david
not much to add i mean to be honest i
think i think i uh
i was i was happy to have spent
just to be able to spend a lot of time
with friends and meeting really good
people expanding the horizon
with with the job opportunities having
been able to work through my second year
get me up to speed i was i had the
opportunity to start spending time in
looking at investing in latin america
and to me that was uh
what i wanted to do i want to make sure
i wanted to spend to go back to latin
america
uh one one of the advices that i
received from mentor was
i think this is helpful perhaps for
everybody in the panels which on the on
the community here which is
strategically you want to position
yourself where there is a scar city and
now what there is over supply
now i always thought that a latin
american that went to the u.s and stayed
in the u.s
had no real differentiation was going
where everybody was
but a latin american that that could go
to the u.s and then go back to latin
america that's where there was real
scarcity and continues to be a scarcity
and so i i think that's ultimately much
very very related to the impact that you
can create in in some of the countries
that we come from
and so to me having been able to to to
have a foot in at stanford but spending
a lot of time with the community and and
investing in latin america and looking
at what was going on in in brazil in
colombia and argentina and our country
was was a really great opportunity so
i'm glad i did that
you guys have uh in combined you've let
companies that in aggregate are worth
more than a hundred billion dollars
um
in latin america you all went you all
came to stanford you all started you all
decided to go back to la tam and start
companies there when you think about
going back to latin america and that and
taking from from where the from where
david just left it
uh
what was the
hardest part
of going back after stanford
so i
i agree very much with what that we just
said i had the opportunity to work at
airbnb
during during the nba um you know and
decided to come back to start a company
out of nowhere and that has no had no
reference outside of brazil so it was i
think the hardest the cool part was to
go and you know and and come back and
and be a
you know an actor of change and trying
to change you know something that really
annoyed me the the experience that we
had in brazil and the opportunity to fix
a problem here and that it was
opportunity for me and also
responsibility you know because
i you know i was i felt like empowered
to take everything that i had learned
there the network that i had and come
back and kind of you know bring to
brazil into latin something that
that uh that could impact many lives
here much probably much more different
than i would have done if i stayed in
the us the hard part was that everything
is harder in latin and everything is
lower in latin you know so there you
know you talk to a bunch of people and
they want to invest here nobody wanted
to invest in us and we spent many many
years you know just bootstrapping with
by the way a few friends from stanford
that were the first angels but it took a
while for us to really have you know a
series a institutional money coming in
which is a very different reality today
uh
and also hard to find talent that just
as i i talked to we were doing that for
the first time we had no real idea of
what we were doing and i would
uh you know have paid a lot more if i if
i could find tainan that uh
that would show me a little bit of the
way and we had to learn almost
everything by
you know from scratch uh i think this is
also changing but it still is a big
difference uh from you know doing
business in brazil or la town comparing
to to the u.s
anybody has a different uh i want to ask
that question to each one of you it's an
important one
what's the hardest part of going back to
la diamond working versus staying in the
u.s for you
i was gonna say like i think the
personality of latin americans is is
amazing it's warm it's it's fun it's
outgoing so building personal
relationships in latin america is great
but but but the way we organize
ourselves as
a society is still far from being
perfect and that's a challenge for
everybody's
daily life when you compare it to the us
or when you compare it to europe i mean
that's that imposes challenges on on how
you raise your family differently on how
you live daily security
issues in the region or social issues in
the region so
so
to some extent it's it's a trade-off on
the quality of life
and the tranquility of life you can lead
that's also very challenging that's also
what makes
uh doing something for the region like
inspiring and and
want to make once
makes you want to do more but it's but
it's a challenge it's a personal
challenge
yeah i i would add you know for me when
there is no playbook no when when you
look at you know at the us what was
going on in silicon valley for
entrepreneurship you know there was
there was some guidelines that would
tell you know you want to get you want
to you know
you know raise money it's going to
appear you want to
include talent in your team you kind of
do these things here at least five years
ago there was nothing you had to kind of
make up everything along the way
and i would also add that
when you want to solve one problem in
america
and you start solving it you need to
solve like 100 surrounding it
like if you want to say i want to start
a company to cell phones and then you
realize okay but there's no connection
to the wire and then i need to add the
connection to the wire okay but now
there's no you know no this no post and
you have to have everything around to
make your business work that if you
probably would have you know if i would
have said in the u.s i would have say
okay i'm only gonna focus on this and
then everything around kind of works and
it's gonna kind of help me to the
environment here you have to assume
nothing around works and you're gonna
have to solve it too so you're gonna
have to build a lot of expertise around
your your your main core business
i
i would say uh sorry were you saying
something mickey go ahead marcus oh
sorry
so i was saying
what first of all i think latin america
is changing a lot and very fast i think
it's important for everyone to have that
in mind because many of the things that
were very hard for example like getting
funding or fun or finding
you know
good technical talent all those things
have improved a lot
and very very fast obviously there's
still a war on talent etc but the same
thing happens you know
everywhere in the world today
so so many things have changed for the
better
having said that i would say
the unpredictability of latin america is
just
incredible it's incredible and the
longer you operate in the region and in
the more countries that you operate
the more impressed you are by how
unpredictable things
are and and that obviously it's fun that
is very fun on the one hand but it's
very hard it makes it very very hard
because it's unpredictable in in many
different uh
ways and uh you know
it can be very hard to build businesses
for the long term you know sometimes
it's politics sometimes it's
unions sometimes it's judges
uh
regulatory frameworks uh you you end up
encountering things that you know you
would never dream of encountering in the
us maybe once every 20 years in latin
america you encounter five of those per
year you know so that that in my opinion
is probably one of the hardest things to
to to build and grow business for the
long term in the in the region and i
don't see unfortunately i don't see that
changing for the better i see it
changing for the worse for example you
know one of our most predictable perhaps
our only predictable market was chile
and all of a sudden chile now has become
a you know
nobody knows where chile is going no no
so it's uh
it's interesting and that's something
that you will not definitely not find in
the us or or in europe
i'm gonna i like this topic of latin
america i want to stay here but i just
have to make a very small there was a
question by francisco somebody named
francisco was actually quite funny he
said all of you guys sound like you have
a very different accent of english and
different level of knowledge of english
how difficult was to do your toefl and
your gmats
and if you remember your score
does anybody remember the score
what's a gmat
[Laughter]
but uh
as expected it was hard you know it was
really hard but i think harder than the
gmat was the first three months at
school trying to really be able to talk
and understand and you read you know
half the speed and when you write you
write like a quarter of the speed it
takes a lot of of pushing and willpower
and headaches to be able to to try to
stay at the level in which you can
actually contribute to the class i don't
know the rest of you agree
and it's not only in the classes you
know because the classes are more formal
more organized so if you're used to to
read and write and you know maybe not so
used to talking but
you can get going the social life is
also very draining you know you go to a
bar and it's loud and everybody's
talking over each other and make jokes
that you don't understand
so it's kind of uh you know you you
think that you go out and you relax but
you come back like exhausted and then
and then you have to keep talking about
it but you know get used to it so it's
part of life and
after after the pain is one of the
benefits as well
the the
there's a lot of questions going back to
la tam
that we have
it's hard to get all of you to be on one
chat so
let's take advantage of that
um
record amounts of money being raised
there has never been a better time to be
an entrepreneur in latin america
and to start something
is this hype is this real
is this like anything that we will it
will go through
different cycles where what is your
mindset uh to this because there's a lot
of questions on the chat coming in from
a lot of people actually trying to
understand
um how important is to fundraise or if
fundraising is a measure of success
how to think about starting a company
today in latin america with all these
founder
abilities to to have money or sustain
some other
some other place so just a little bit
um
love to get your thoughts
on those topics
ricky you should you should answer that
one
you're investigatively in the region
fair um so
i too was an entrepreneur in the region
as most of you know and
i am shocked with the amount of capital
that is available to to start i wish
that had been the case 20 years ago or
even 10 years ago or even i had a chance
to meet david when he was raising his
sidra and i passed um
he was a colombian going to brazil but
you know we corrected the mistake later
in life and we invested later but
i would say what is different is
it's just the quality of the mission of
the people i find that for the first
time ever i'm seeing
people who truly want to change the
region and have the tools and the
technologies there these days to do it
so
i find that to be different
than any time before uh in terms of what
can be done
but i do think
that the record amount of money is not a
recipe for success
if anything
i'm more concerned that it will
it will create
uh the wrong incentives and greed will
overtake the mission
uh that's what i worry the most right
now
i'll just just i would just add to that
and you obviously you see you probably
have the best perspective from all those
given you're investing actually but
whenever you take whenever you actually
see the big numbers even if the the
money has increased a lot in latin
america it's still very much below what
you would see in other geographies even
compared to
to asia or to india or to us so
availability of capital is really
everywhere and
yes it's great that it has improved
latin america but it's still relatively
small
compared to the size of the opportunity
that exists in the region
and
i think it's at a point right now where
people are still very much
grabbing the capital and being
responsible with it
you generally do see businesses that
have good
business model real unit economics real
uh business fundamentals since the very
beginning
you still haven't really seen a lot of
the craziness that you sometimes i think
you see in the u.s and europe i think
i think it's i would i would say still
it's becoming more appropriate but it
hasn't gone to the point where it's
absurd or
or people are wasting money all over the
place at least that's my my one
my two cents on the on that perspective
yeah i would add that uh
you know it was hard for me in the
beginning to envision that you know we
would build companies
they scale that we're seeing some some
of the companies here in the speed that
we're seeing these companies grow
and it's very good to see some examples
that that's possible and you see as
robust companies you know with strong
talent platforms strong cultures you
know they really know how to develop
products that will you know solve big
problems
uh
i and i then you know i think we what
dodea is saying is just it's just a a
follow-up to that but the challenge uh
for myself that i you know sometimes we
are we struggle here is like as marcus
was saying it's very unpredictable in in
latin and so on one hand it's very good
to put money in the bank
and you know and then you you know
comparing to a few years ago where you
didn't have the money in the bank and
you had to keep going so it's much
better to have the money in the bank but
you don't know if that if if this wave
is gonna is it is gonna continue or just
be a short wave of capital that comes
comes and goes and then this this you
know push and break it's kind of hard in
the companies and if you know if we
could have more predictability and more
um
stability of this capital and you could
plan
around it you know it would be much uh
healthier for the companies i think to
to not be
you know to agree that i need to raise
no data and then raise a bunch of
capital maybe more than you need babe at
the valuation higher than than you
should and you know and you spend that
in a way that maybe a year or two from
now you won't sustain the same rhythm
and then you have to pull back in the
company so that's kind of uh one of the
hardest things in latin i've seen the
last two years for example every quarter
or every semester we had to cut to
adjust our plan
due to external factors in a way that
was like man you know you kept i know
that's a dynamic business and we are
adjusting all the time but uh but in
latin is kind of a bit more exciting and
i think funding
coming and going uh is one of the
biggest reasons for that
i think it's
it's i mean sometimes i think the hype
where their cyber reality i think
sometimes you don't know until you know
until things unravel
but not thinking about the future but
about the past and i compare the
headlines of today and they may seem
somewhat exuberant but to the headlines
of approximately 12 15 years ago and the
kind of companies that were raising
money or companies that were doing
um oil exploration in the colombian
amazonian bases basin or in the presult
in brazil and that was the exuberance
then and i'd rather much have
the kind of money that is flowing today
into the region flow into the kind of
businesses that are that it's flowing
into and let it let there be a bubble
there bubbles always tend to correct
then in the kind of sectors that we were
seeing it flowing into not more than
not about a decade ago so i'd rather
much have this
kind of market dynamics this kind of
destination for money than the ones that
the region saw in previous cycles
and i would add that you know beyond the
money i'm i'm very very excited about
what i'm seeing because i'm seeing a lot
of talent
there are a lot of people now that's
entrepreneurship that really want to you
know take on a problem and solve it and
they're seeing with a capital flow that
it's something that can be done so i
think it's just going to be a lot more
stories of entrepreneurship from latin
america people doing amazing things
because i'm seeing the people that want
to become entrepreneurs that want to
join an entrepreneur you know an
entrepreneurial team which is amazing
and we didn't have that five years ago
dory there's a question that came up a
couple times around you're the only
woman in this panel
uh
how do you how do you see the latin
american startup environment evolving
for more gender uh equality
usually i'm the only woman in the panel
unless it's an only women panel which
they're not a lot
um
well there's still a lot to do there are
a lot of social things going on in latin
america that have been going on for a
while in terms of you know what's the
women's role and how we could do so we
still
we're not there yet
we still need to figure out a way to to
to get more women interested in becoming
entrepreneurs get more women interested
not only in becoming entrepreneurs but
in solving
bigger problems because as women we
usually tend to go to smaller markets we
need to go to bigger markets and and
also to trust ourselves more that we
were that we're going to do it so
it's going to take a little bit but i
i know we're a few women here and in you
know as entrepreneurs and we're going to
we're really trying to see how we can
have a multiplying effect
uh
david you had a co-founder you have a
christina as a co-founder in new bank
as
as you think about and you see a lot of
people that are starting companies in
brazil have you seen any any
any other changes there
yeah i think i think i've seen changes i
don't i don't think it's as fast as
as we all wish uh
i
i think chris my co-founder is still one
of the few
brazilian co-founders of one of the
large tech companies and that's very
surprising
in a country where over half the percent
50 population are women uh but i but i
see more and more it's happening more
and more
there is not only more women going in
starting their own businesses but also
venture capital focused on supporting
women-led businesses and i think the
just entire ecosystem is is arranging
itself to make it much more inclusive
and and and available so
i i think it's still early it's
definitely not where it should be but
but it's but the train is good
uh one and the one question that comes a
lot here is
how are you recruiting people for your
companies what language is the official
language companies are speaking
when you hear when you hire
technologists and
developers in different regions uh
as latin america becomes uh as all of
you are growing to multiple countries
how is that an issue an opportunity in
the future
so let me put this way uh
marcos what's your official language in
medical delivery on the in the
technology team
oh many
meaning coding language or
speaking language when you have people
from different countries
we it's spanish typically it's spanish
uh historically when i speak to stelio
we communicate in english and and the
official language all the presentations
every material that is written in the
company is written in english so our
board operates in english we present to
our investors in english so we present
to ourselves even though we might be
speaking in spanish the written material
everything is in english
and
you know
brazil is 60 of our revenues uh so so
but most of the people speak spanish in
the company but it's kind of out of
respect to to the brazilians we we we
use a a neutral language which is
english uh oftentimes when we are
communicating with our brazilian teams
david
we we started with english first we had
a team where one of my co-founders is
american the our co-founder is brazilian
i'm colombian
so
english ended up being the default
in our
team of the first 10 15 employees there
were already a number of people from the
us that didn't speak any spanish or
portuguese so english became the kind of
the the lingua franca of the entire
company
that has been an opportunity as well as
a challenge i think opportunity is that
as we go now globally and expand where
we're recruiting talent
we already have people from 45 different
nationalities
we're very spread around that becomes a
match it's already a culture that is
everything is in english all the
documentation is in english people can
can get up to speak quickly in what's
going on and it's easier for people from
around the world to
to to get integrated with different
teams the challenge staff thought is
that especially in the early stages in
some of the countries a lot of people
don't speak english
and you might become a very exclusionary
company if you require english
as a requirement to enter you might be
leaving a lot of really important talent
that just doesn't speak english you
didn't have the opportunity so the
challenge is how do you
provide english lessons how do you have
pre-inclusive uh
your hr processes recruiting processes
to allow to recruit people sometimes
from lower income segments that don't
speak english train them in english and
make them able to
to really fit within the company that's
one of the biggest challenges that we're
working right now because i don't think
the answer also is we're an english
company
and all latin americans need to figure
out how to speak english at the end of
the day we are the latin american
company right so so so it's the
challenge is finding that mix
and ultimately it's about
the spanish people have to learn
portuguese and english the portuguese
people have to speak spanish and english
and try to get everybody to speak all
the languages ultimately work in some
kind of
mixture that that that so far is is
working
gabriel in quinto and
yeah i think it's about the same thing
we're still
not operating in in other countries uh
but i you know since the beginning we we
also have you know internal
documentation in english and you know
sometimes we have the opportunity to
bring people from from outside even
before the the remote world phenomena uh
and i think that's an opportunity i you
know it's the challenge
uh for everybody to adapt to that but as
you know you know they said here i think
it's also the opportunity to force us to
do that so if you have a chance of
working a company that will allow you
and force you and require you to
to develop english you know you just
it's just better than
you know going to school and not
practicing it outside uh so i think it's
a forcing mechanism and is inevitable
uh so
nothing very very different to add there
well it feels that we have a the common
learning here is uh english is an
important language for presentations and
for
recruiting uh
challenging getting up more and more
people's companies grow to speak the
language or or to get the basics running
but uh it is it is something that
i will tell you was not the case 15 20
years ago so it's changing in the region
and it's changing really really fast
we're going to transition there's one
question that i'm going to answer but as
we transition to having the
stanford team give a little bit of some
some data on gsb
um there's a there's a question here
that says i feel venezuela is a
different case from most of the region
given his current economic condition
what would you recommend to an aspiring
mba student
who would like to eventually come back
to his country and make a difference
so i'm going to take a stab at answering
that question guys feel free to jump in
if you want to
but uh to that question this is part of
the reason why
um i started si se puede which you're
going to hear in a couple minutes a
little bit more about from this team at
stanford we're basically um
creating this program that allows any
latin america to apply
the indian latin american has certain
financial conditions below a certain
salary range to apply for free to stand
first business school and once
you get admitted and you get accepted
there's a program where we will sponsor
have a fellowship and have
a few a few students per year that will
get uh
scholarships to go to attend and get
most of his uh tuition paid for by si se
puede which is uh i i which is with the
purpose that if you go back to the
region
after studying and you end up having an
impact and you're not going back to the
country that you you are from
we will waive any other debt you have
remaining so the idea is to get more
people to attend school in the ins in
the us get prepared with the way
marcos laurie david
gave heronimo were had a chance to be
exposed go back to the region have an
impact and do it in a way that is cost
efficient for you
and that's part of what we want to do is
venezuela in particular i hear you i'm
from venezuela it's hard to go back now
but you can definitely go back to the
region and we'll cross our fingers and
when it gets better and we can enter
this generation of people that went to
these business schools that had
that build these networks of
relationships will have the impact to
change an entire country the same way
all of you are changing
uh your countries by bringing better
financial services better e-commerce
better ways to buy or finance a car
better ways to buy or finance your home
or finance or final rent so
these are all things that impact society
and there and funny enough we got
an amazing group that went to this
school and had a chance to do this
so with that i want to transition
quickly to the stanford team
to see if they have anything they want
to add thank you mickey um thank you so
much to mickey and our panelists this
was just uh fantastic and the time flew
by i feel like i could listen to your
insights for a long time so just much
appreciated and mickey thank you so much
for um teeing up the information about
si se puede as mickey mentioned
and thanks to his generous support um we
are so excited to offer this program at
the gsb specifically to those who are
from latin america who
meet as mickey mentioned a certain
financial condition that's making less
than u.s forty thousand dollars um when
you apply to the gsb if you meet these
conditions your application fee will be
waived um
so this is not something you need to
apply for there's no additional
paperwork needed and this will just
happen um in your application um if you
meet these conditions
we're so excited to be offering this so
for those of you who are on today thank
you for joining us so you can learn
about this and for those who are just
hearing about it feel free to share this
with your friends too i did see a
question in the chat um just is this the
same as knight hennessy and that's a
great question as mickey mentioned not
only are we trying to
make it possible for you to apply um
with this application fee waiver but we
want to enable you to be able to attend
also um should you get in so mickey
mentioned the fellowship money that is
available our financial aid is once you
are admitted our financial aid is
need-based so
should you have a high level of need
there are fellowships available to help
you be able to attend and one of the
questions that was out there is is this
the same as knight hennessy i want to
point out that there are fellowships
specifically to support students from
latin america but there are also many
other fellowship programs such as knight
hennessy that's another way for you to
apply to that program separately you um
you know would have the potential to be
a night hennessey fellow as well as
a stanford gsb student though so si se
puede and night hennessy are separate
programs
um but they are indicative of the level
of support that's out there for you to
be able to attend the gsb there are
millions of dollars of fellowships
awarded our average fellowship each year
per student is around 40 000 that's
average meaning many students get more
um than that and so you know whatever
year you are thinking about applying i
encourage you to seek out what financial
programs are available but right now si
se puede is available
as an application fee waiver and
fellowships should you um be able to
attend
in addition to many other programs we
have
so i did see a few other questions in
the chat that were admissions focused um
so i encourage you all to check our
events page if you are interested in
attending an information session that's
more about the application about the
application process and we'd love to
have you there and help you learn more
about applying to the gsb
um i know we're a few minutes over so
again i just want to wrap up in thanking
mickey so much for not only his support
of this program for but for helping
bring this dynamic panel together it was
such a great event um so great to hear
all of your insights
i thank you all for your time um and
again thank you to everyone who attended
today uh it was great to have you with
us and i hope you found this as
inspirational as i did
one one last question to finish to the
panelists who was the best student
i was not in that top 10 percent i could
tell you that
neither was i
so i'll finish it up by saying uh to all
of you thank you i know you're super
busy i appreciate you taking an hour of
your day for this
appreciate all of you thank you lisa
from stanford for putting this together
and
we look forward to seeing a lot of
admissions a lot of applications and
hopefully a lot of fellowships from sisa
puede for more latin americans to come
to stanford and then go back and have an
impact in south america
[Music]
you